hello everyone and welcome to the first
ever couch list video on my channel now
there's a very good reason why the couch
behind me is missing but it's it's a
fairly long story so I will maybe tell
it if you're interested in a week when
the couch returns now getting back to
this game it's the final round of the
gushy move Memorial Causton has already
won the tournament so this is just a
game where he can either improve his
rating performance you know get a few
more rating points but all in all the
tournament standings are not all that
important to him anymore
here he faces Alexander Grisha can a
great trick mentioned in the previous
video that he was very sad that Kirk in
lost his game like that because now
there is no chance for anyone to catch
up to Magnus but at least he now gets a
crack at the world champion so without
further ado let's check out the game
it's a very nice line of the Berlin
where calls and chooses a very rare
align so let's check it out their course
and opens with E 4 we have E 5 Knight to
f3 Knight to c6 and Bishop to b5 now the
real Lopez is on the board we have
Knight to f6 and now d3 and of course
Bishop to c5 the the most common played
line of the Berlin today c3 by Carlsen
preparing the early retreat of the
bessarovia via Bishop 284 in situ with
castles by Grecian Ockham's castles by
caution these six and now immediately
Bishop to a4
we have Knight to e7 by Grisha quarry
maneuvering the night over to g6 and now
right away Bishop to c2 by cousin here
there is there are three moves known in
this position as it's not all that often
played line but the most notable game
from this position is a 30-acre conversa
Demetria coming over Knight B to d2 was
played and Kerrigan was able to win this
game in last year's world the Bliss
championship in st. Petersburg but here
cross and goes Bishop to c2 so it's only
moving but already calls and when Bishop
b5 to a4 - C - this is if you're a
beginner you shouldn't touch your pieces
more than once in the opening but if
you're you know they're familiar with
the line then it's okay
Knight to g6 and by the way butter up
the c2 is a new move
the position which is I move 8 for the
Berlin defence a very rare thing and for
the rule up is in general Grisha
continues Knight to g6 as planned
and now d4 agony shook is not interested
in capturing in the center he doesn't
want to make it easy for Carlsen so
retreating with the Bishop Ussher b6 and
now a for grabbing space on the Queen
side also a5 will come c6 making an
escape route for the bishop if Carson
does push a 5 and now pawn captures on
e5 with Knight captures Knight captures
pawn captures in here cousin can choose
whether he wants the trade Queens or
maybe keep the Queens on the board but
he already won the tournament he plays
Queen captures on d8 we have rook
captures on d8 and now comes a 5 just
pushing that butter back with Bishop not
the c7 although it seems like a very
nice square but perhaps agree sure we
did not find it all that impressive
since this point is on e5 blocking the
nice and dark square bishop so Bishop to
c5 we have Knight to e2 by cousin he
continues development Bishop to e6 and
now comes Luke to e1 rook to e1 is a
nice move because it's it gives Greece
shook the opportunity to go Bishop the
knife the g4 to put some threats along D
the F pawn were cross and could either
go look at one and then goose could
repeat hoping for for a nice draw but
also Carson Crossing can just guard upon
via rook to e2 so that is possible but
then he constantly has to keep an eye on
the light square bishop if it will
harass the rook but ok after Luke you
want this shoe goes b5 he also wants to
expand on the Queen side and perhaps if
cousin is interested in trading then
even trade rooks along the a file but
cousin just repeats Knight to b3 forces
the bishop to move back or or allows the
Bishop captures and b3 here Grisha
decides to give up the bishop pair we
have Bush of captures on b3 with Bishop
captures on d3 and now Knight to g4
piling up on the f2 pawn and here if
Carson goes back to f1
most likely we should would just repeat
Knight to f6 so cross and goes look - E
- it's not a problem
as there's no no danger of ruby 1
since the bishop is covering the d1
square we have ripped the d6 very shook
now hopes to double rooks along the D
file but first we have Bishop to g5
crossing the law develops his dark
squared Bishop also guards the d8 square
so Luke 2d sorry so rook to d8 will not
be possible
we have kinked f8 now you still can't
push f6 to push the bishop back as
there's this very annoying pin so 1st
degree should breaks the pin King to f8
and now comes looked rook to f1 also you
could play something like h3 but black
will just ignore you black and go h6 or
f6 and then well well we will probably
get the same position as in the game
rook to f1 by Carlsen preparing g3 King
G 2 and f4 we have Knight back to f6 by
Grisha you could also play f6 but then
just Bishop 2 c1
yes you've kicked the dark square bishop
back but you do now have this well a
monster light square bishop and you
don't have a light square bishop
yourself to it to a post constant light
square bishop so you don't want to allow
this so instead of creating any
weaknesses in front of your king Knight
back to f6 we have g3 as planned across
the most of all King g2 and f4
we have a six by three shook and now
King to g2 Knight back to D seven and
now bushra back to c1 cross and once his
Bishop to be behind the DF for pawn when
he pushes it he doesn't want to lock it
in with f4 so Bishop to c1 Bushra back
to a7 guru also wants to push on the
Queen side and now f4 and here cross and
puts on an additional defender to the
two the f-35 phone so he plays f6 again
or seemingly one of the positions where
it is okay to play f6 and Carlsen goes
h4 he now wants to grab even more space
on the Kings side we have rook to e8
defending yet again the e5 pawn over
protecting it if you will with h5 by
Carlsen and now h6 not allowing the pawn
to create even more weaknesses by being
pushed all the way to h6
Bishop to a2 by Carlson with ideas of
going bishop to be one as there are some
very interesting lines here which
probably Carlsen prepared already even
here
but okay we have c5 and here cross and
decides to sacrifice a pawn and it's a
very nice pawn sacrifice because it
gives white a lot of activity and since
Grisha pays in time trouble which I know
what you're thinking Grisha is always in
time trouble that's not really a big
deal but you know it is a big deal if
it's a complicated position and you have
to act quickly
so Crossing goes Bishop to e3 he
prevents any expansion on the Queen set
because the bishop on a7 is unguarded
but good accepts the pawn sacrifice we
have he captures on f4 pawn captures on
f4 and now Luke captures on e4 and here
the bishop now comes to be one forcing
the rook to move back rook to e7 is
played and now of course bishop there
pair will be very strong here we have
rook F d1 here cross and doubles up on
the e-file and the Grichuk now has to
decide how to do what to do his Bishop
isn't doing all that much
the knight isn't really all that
impressive he is up upon but he still
has to mobilize his pieces - well - more
impressive squares here tonight the b8
would have been the best idea followed
by Knight to c6 and from there you can
continue just you know building of the
position but he decides to give back the
point immediately I put his pieces on
better squares he plays f5 give us back
the F pawn and now he wants to use the
f6 square for the knight and go all the
way to d5 so here cousin accepts the you
know the pawn sacrifice back we have a
knight to f6 and now just King to have
three by Carlsen here
Grisha replies with Knight to d5 just
piling up on the bishop on e3 but Knight
the d5 doesn't work and Knight to d5
actually loses the game for good but
feel free to pause the video and try to
find a move that well takes advantage of
this in inaccuracy by a bug reshoot
I'll give you a couple of seconds if
you're interested in maybe trying a
given air to go for those of you who
were able to do it - congratulations you
were an excellent tactician and for
those of you who just want to enjoy it
show the most rook to d2 just notice
that the rook on d6 is unguarded the
knight can never move and you can attack
the knight all we want you can go rogue
one you can go Bishop to e4 it will be
very hard for black to defend this as I
mean it's it's very obvious when you
have all the time in the world but a
gray ship in severe time trouble he
missed this this idea so he goes rogue
back to d8 now preparing for for
Carlson's onslaught on the d5 square
bishop the e4 by Carson and now just
rook d7 as the bishop is no longer
controlling the d7 square but Carson
just attacks it again we have rook eat
d1 and now how do you defend it you play
Knight to f6 but it doesn't work the
thing you had to realize when you played
roof to d2 is the weak a sex pawn and
here Carson really takes advantage of it
he plays rook captures on d7 and now if
you exchange everything if you go rook
captures captures captures and then
Bishop to b7 the whole Queen side pawn
structure falls apart and you will have
a winning endgame so here gray ship
tried Knight captures on d7 but it
doesn't matter a cross and just played
Luke the d6 and now there's again no way
to defend the exponent once the a6 pawn
falls it's the base of the pawn chain
all the other points will follow and
it's an easy winning endgame for Magnus
Carlsen yeah what to say brilliant third
in a row victory for Magnus Carlsen who
finishes this tournament all the other
games have ended as well so I will show
the standings these are the standings as
you can see Carlsen wins the tournament
with two points ahead of everyone else
so Magnus Carlsen seven points Dingley
ran in second place followed by kuraki
and also with five points in third place
then with four and a half we have three
people Alexandre Greece shook after
losing this game to Carlsen Viswanathan
Anand team or a job of then with four
points Veselin Topalov and David navara
and with three and a half share
mamedyarov
and unbelievable but a former member of
the 2800 Club onigiri in the last place
with only three points but as we already
mentioned someone always has to have a
bad tournament if others are to win some
points which is what happened to Gary
this tournament but he's playing another
tournament fairly soon so I think you
already forgot about this event and you
know he's just moving forward with a
life and everything
which is definitely the way to go
everyone can have a bad tournament but
then you just have to pick herself up
and say okay there are more games to be
played Steph that's the game I do hope
you enjoyed it really really an
impressive tournament by Carlson who won
it the fourth time this is the fourth
edition of the frontier chess tournament
he won all four and this time he wanted
wood wood a two point lead and yeah his
rating performance in this tournament is
almost three thousand and in in the live
rating he he has now climbed above
twenty eight sixty so he's getting
closer and closer to his to his highest
highest ever rating which I believe was
twenty eight hundred and eighty two so
who knows if he continues this up until
the end of the year he could he could
very well be the first person to at the
break 2900 but it's it's a really an end
it seems like impossible because if you
just lose one game then you know you
have to win like five games just to make
up for that one so it's it's really
really hard I don't think it will be
possible just yet but you know maybe
maybe next year when more people will
feed into the rating system where when
there will be a lot more rating on top
then perhaps you know more players will
start breaking twenty nine hundred maybe
not next year maybe I said a bit too
soon for Carlson maybe but for others
maybe in in a five years range but yeah
yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I will consider showing some
other games we'll see how it goes
feel free to suggest some other games if
you're interested in checking up in this
tournament well we have suggested
England versus the Paolo where
everything just squeezes the blood out
of stone but it's it's really not
there's nothing to show there how to put
it which would which would educate you
or show you something or or even make it
an entertaining it's just the dings
incredible willpower that allowed him to
to tackle that but yeah I would like to
thank Dom I put what its harsh II try a
team of solo Harrison Beaudry and Paul
staples for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check - on my previous
videos here thank you all for watching
and I will see you soon hopefully with
some more interesting
and hopefully would a couch behind me
and you know now I will tell you that
story once the couch returns but we'll
see about that so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day